the one issue that continues to linger
and we got some
i don't know that i want to call it good
news it was kind of confusing news last
week pete carroll the seahawks coach
said thursday that a team had called him
about the visit that the seahawks had
with colin kaepernick back in 2017 and
it's the first time pete carroll had
heard from anyone else in the league
about the visit they had with colin
kaepernick which creates the impression
that
that
someone may be interested in colin
kaepernick drew rosenhaus had some
comments to nbc news
over the weekend and one very important
point that caused me to go back to the
original comments from colin kaepernick
and dust them off and what rosenhaus
said is
that kaepernick was really ahead of his
time with a lot of the things he was
saying
if you play many of his interviews from
years ago they're spot on today and
chris it really is amazing i want to
read to you one of the first things
colin kaepernick had to say about this
in august of 2016.
there is police brutality people of
color have been targeted by police so
that's a large part of it and they're
government officials they're put in a
place by the government so that's
something that this country has to
change there's things we can do to hold
them more accountable and make those
standards higher
you have people that practice law and
our lawyers go to law school for eight
years
but you can become a cop in six months
and don't have to have the same amount
of training as a cosmetologist that's
insane someone that's holding a curling
iron has more education and more
training than people have a gun and are
going out on the street to protect us
and i looked it up at the time in
california 888 hours was what you needed
to get your police certification 600
hours is what you needed to hold a
curling iron so he was right he was
right and when you see what happened
friday night and it's difficult video to
watch when you see what happened to ray
sharp brooks in the wendy's parking lot
it becomes abundantly clear that there
are people out there
who have the ability the license the
authority to use deadly force and don't
know how in the hell to use it and don't
know when to use it and don't know when
they shouldn't use it and don't know how
to restrain themselves when they get
punched in the face and the guy takes
off with their stun gun and they've got
their emotions and adrenaline going they
don't know how to how to refrain from
resorting to the lethal force that they
have attached to their hip chris so
there does need to be better training
there does need to be higher standards
he was right all along and that's kind
of where we are right now we're seeing
and saying
this guy was right all along
well i mean
if this weekend doesn't prove that it's
a real issue then i mean of course we
knew it was but i mean this weekend just
accentuates you accentuates it mike i
mean with all that's going on in the
world
you know a cop is gonna pull his gun on
a guy who he's already got all the
information of
yes he's got your stun gun but as we
know that is not a deadly tool
but we're gonna shoot him like he's
running away with the keys to the united
states or something i don't understand
that
and that just tells you that there is
issues here i mean in the current
climate where you can't turn on a news
channel right now and they're not
talking about
police brutality and the injustice
injustices of the african-american
society and yet there we were on a
friday night with a white cop and an
african-american you know being arrested
he runs and you shoot him i mean
because he's got a taser
i mean can't we just call other cops and
go chase them and maybe just get him
that way i mean when was it like now
this is wild game and we just shoot
people like oh he's he's running i mean
it's just insane so it just accentuates
the problem and strengthens the case of
the reality of what's going on here in
this country and that's what's
infuriating is some people don't want to
see it some people are still making
excuses for friday night it's just
unbelievable but we just got to keep
knocking at the door and educating
people and hopefully we can turn most
people around
i saw an interview over the weekend with
someone from the police union who is
going to say all of the perfunctory
things that this was justified and it
was nonsensical what the guy was trying
to say to justify this someone on msnbc
friday night said it's not like this guy
was going to have a helicopter emerge
out of nowhere and take him off to
kathmandu this isn't a serial killer who
was moving on to his next victim it was
a guy who was asleep in his car he was
drunk he broke the law he was going to
face the consequences for it and then he
was going to face enhanced consequences
for
resisting arrest with violence that's a
felony in most jurisdictions that's a
problem he was in trouble but that
doesn't justify the police officer in
that moment acting as judge jury and
executioner with no chance for the
governor to call and give a reprieve
that's what we're talking about folks
these people are walking around in our
communities with guns and they have the
license to use those guns
whenever they decide that it's
appropriate and yes there are
consequences when you use it
incorrectly but you know what whatever
consequence that cop faces is nothing
like the consequence that ray shard
brooks faced he didn't deserve to die he
deserved to be in trouble he didn't
deserve to die and the people who are
issued the guns and the ability to use
those guns in the line of duty need to
be held to a higher standard that is not
anti-cop if i was a cop i'd like to
think i'd be very conscientious about
use of force i'd like to think that i
was committed to doing the right thing
at all times and i'd like to think i'd
be damn pissed off if there were other
people out there in my community in my
state in my country that made me look
bad that i have to deal with their crap
because they don't know when to keep the
gun in the holster when to pull it out
and when to pull the trigger i would be
so pissed about that if i was a cop and
i would say any good cop out there
should be upset about it we hear that
excuse oh well there's just a few bad
apples well it looks like there's more
than a few first of all but all the good
apples need to stand up and find the bad
apples and throw them the hell out of
the bushel
yeah well that you're right that's
that's a good point you know i could
speak just as an nfl player when we had
a few bad apples right bad apples you
know guys in the locker room guys in the
league you know
yeah right wait when players didn't dump
in stupid things though
you know
like
well yeah you felt like you've cheated
us all i know you're joking but yeah
that's what you feel like you're just
like i mean gosh you're giving us all a
bad name by what you did you know this
weekend or getting arrested or whatever
it may be so you know and then yes
within that you try to correct that guy
in the locker room like hey man you're
better than that don't be doing that
crap it looks bad on all of us it just
doesn't seem like that goes on sometimes
in the police it seems like nope i know
you were wrong but we're gonna support
you and your wrongness because we're
policemen and we're all together and
you're wrong so i don't know but we're
supporting you and i just that makes no
sense either you're right i'd like to
see a little bit more accountability
there and trust me i am very sensitive
to how tough that job is i understand it
and i'm very thankful for the police
department and everything they do i
really do get it you know they've helped
me many times in my life family members
whatever it may be i know there's a lot
of good ones but like you're saying it
just seems like there's a few more than
just a few bad apples out there right
now and we need to fix that
and you know the one point i didn't make
as they decided that this man who was
drunk and was running away with their
taser needed to be shot and killed there
was a line of cars in the drive-through
at the wendy's you get a stray bullet
you get a bystander killed is that
really the kind of serious immediate
risk that justifies the wild west
approach and bang bang shoot him up i
mean it really really is disheartening
that it happened post george floyd at a
time when people are supposed to be
understanding
these issues and acting accordingly you
just wonder how much of that is getting
through to the people who need to be
hearing the message so look hey we're
here we have the platform that's crossed
over to the nfl and i think it's
important to make these points one last
thing on kaepernick before we take a
break
and when i think back to 2017
the paralysis that teams like the ravens
had and other teams that were concerned
they were going to lose fans right
that's why they stayed away that's why
they all stayed away from kaepernick
it's a business to see has has anybody
stopped to think has anybody tapped into
the expertise they have in-house to run
the numbers on what it would mean to
sign this guy setting aside right and
wrong setting aside that he should be in
the league setting this setting aside
the fact that he's been shunned and
blackballed by the nfl has anybody
bothered to sit down and think about
what it would mean in this moment to
your to your business if it was business
interest that got you
to stay away from him three years ago i
mean first of all he gets signed by
somebody you got the number one jersey
in the nfl right out of there no doubt
right out of the gate no doubt i don't
know how much money teams make off of
that you got the number one jersey
throughout the country you have a
national following right out of the
gates whatever team you are these teams
want to do hard knocks to get a national
following you're not going to get a
national following from hard knocks you
may get nationally ridiculed based upon
all the dumb stuff that comes through
the tv screen you're going to get a
national following if you sign colin
kaepernick and you're going to have your
brand mentioned you're going to have
fans that are going to want to come to
your games and it's going to off i think
at this point
i'd like to think there's someone out
there who can crunch the numbers for any
of the teams that may be interested and
come to the conclusion this is a net
gain at this point regardless of what's
right or wrong it's i think it's shifted
to the point chris where it is a good
business decision and i'm just waiting
for someone to come to that conclusion
yeah i agree with you and i think you're
right i mean it's going to be big time
jersey sales you know we saw this when
nike gave colin kaepernick the contract
i mean their stock went through the roof
you know more people gravitated toward
it i think it is the time right now to
where yes there's enough people woke and
aware of the situation and want to see
change and kaepernick such a powerful
name and such a powerful figure in this
movement that will bring people to
fandom of the nfl that you know simply
maybe just oh that team won this sunday
great now they might tune in and watch
you do you make this type of of move and
sign a colin kaepernick you know that
makes this type of statement would be
huge to
uh i think the country and yeah you're
gonna lose a few fans but i think
ultimately you're right mike you'll end
up gaining more fans than you lose
all right uh we'll see how that plays
out the other point that i made over the
weekend too that that uh you know when
you think back to jackie robinson and
branch ricky and how branch ricky is
remembered by history and i know this is
far different than the jackie robinson
situation but there are similarities
this is a player who by some is reviled
who by some they believe he should not
be in the nfl and they'll huff and puff
and and threaten to blow your house down
if if he's on your team and and uh you
know just from the standpoint of how
people want to be remembered on the back
end of this time in history i'd like to
think there's some coach general manager
owner out there that would that would
love to seize the opportunity to be
remembered in such a positive light as
the person who stood up and said i'm
going to do the right thing here and i'm
bringing colin kaepernick back to the
nfl we'll see if that happens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports